[Musique]
bon bah c'est bien un encore une bonne
réunion qui se termine on peut y aller
bonne soirée
mystère sont le mime et arrête avec
cette devise toutes les deux minutes
et puis tu là crie maintenant en plus
c'est vrai vous en pensez quoi vous
soyez pas choqué comme ça je me suis
emporté mais est-ce que les mystères
sont de mise
ça veut vraiment dire quelque chose
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien apparemment quelqu'un a essayé de
planter ce couteau dans mon dos sans
cette armure de dragon j'étais plus là
c'est officiellement une tentative de
meurtre je pense que malheureusement
l'assassin et parmi vous véhicule ma vie
c'est ridicule c'est pas moi suce il ya
un moyen très simple de déterminer à qui
appartient cette arme que chacun sorte
son couteau on est tous censés avoir un
couteau
voilà c'est la tradition mais ça sert
essentiellement pour la boue clarisse
moi j'ai pas de couteaux j'ai des supers
sauvage
b lire très bien à présent que chacun
sorte sont deuxièmes couteaux quoi j'ai
pas de deuxième couteau bon j'ai un
deuxième couteau mais c'est parce que le
château est hyper dangereux aussi
mais merde c'était d'élire les autres
avait pas de mobile il n'avait pas son
deuxième couteau traditionnel et aussi
il y avait son nom sur la lave je le
savais depuis le début mais pense pas
mais je vous dis que c'est pas parce que
je suis d'athlètes de bénir c'est moi
seigneur du château
le qatar a fait construire à vence noc
et du vin des enclumes ici c'est moi qui
peut tout changer
bonjour prisonniers moi je préfère vous
le dire tout de suite hein c'est pas de
la faire de conneries parce que si vous
faites un truc contre moi ça se
retournera contre nous parce que je sers
de château de caen sortir d'ici je ne
dirai pas où je parle j'ai pas peur non
j'ai pas peur c'est mon débit naturel
c'est à vous nous adapter moi je m'en
fous tu as mangé pas rester ici très
très longtemps parce que moi à l'heure
qu'il est mais ils sont riches en train
de peiner pour ma défense
c'est un connard c'est vrai nom c'est un
connard oui mais en même temps quel
serait le meilleur châtiment pour la
connerie t on veut pas qu'ils souffrent
mais un peu de changement ça fait du
bien quand même temps mais je crois
qu'on se reprend tout à fait vous voulez
du changement mais vous voulez pas
qu'ils souffrent c'est sa part fait bon
ne vous inquiétez pas je serai clément
avec plaisir
homme de cachot je sais que votre monde
est plein de violence et de cruauté un
univers plein de peur et de ténèbres à
les préjugés ou alors on est des
sauvages le sait le cachot les gars oui
non mais ça va on est civilisés on est
on est pas des bêtes non plus y'a pas de
quoi oui peut-être parfois ça arrive
s'il ya un feeling à la cool entre nous
on en a l'air on se rend déjà des petits
services vous l'avez acheté reste
exceptionnel et fait attention parce que
je suis désolé mais toi avec tes clichés
ça donne pas envie à la demande et reyes
passera que dalle je suis désolé ce que
je pensais que les conditions étaient
hyper difficile
ah ouais là par contre ça se saurait si
horrible il fait froid ces milliards il
a bouffé se fait tabasser tous les jours
on voit de la piste et c'est pour sa
fête de l'entraidé faut être copains
quoi c'est fort ça me donne une leçon de
vie mais voir des illettrés réagir avec
tant de noblesse
bah moi ça me va mieux ça me bouleverse
le mec il a des pieds mais tout propre
mais genre propre qu'ils sont blancs des
pieds blancs ouais et alors il n'y a pas
d'odeur quoi joris il sent bien il a des
fois il est là non je crois qu'ils
m'aiment bien
c'est la première fois je me fais des
potes c'est vite puis j'apprends plein
de trucs hier par exemple quand tu mets
ta main devant la bouche là comme ça ça
veut dire que c'est gênant ce que tu dis
part avec le nouveau seigneur ça se pose
pas super bien je pense que cette
aventure va faire de moi un meilleur
senior dès que je retiens ici je
m'arrangerai pour leur offrir une
couverture en plus et des chaussettes
parce que ça pue
mais lire regarder qui voit là à hélice
bonjour alors comment ça se passe ici ça
se passe super bien figure toi je me
suis fait plein de nouveaux copains et
on s'éclate comme des petits fous
saleh sexuelles non mais parce que c'est
pas sexuel ruby mais je juge bien mais
ça aurait pu arriver mais ça là ça peut
pas rester longtemps par contre alors
pourquoi tu as d'autres potes à trahir
non parce que ça sent mauvais et que ça
dérange pas on finit la conversation
dehors c'est plus sympa oh ben non tu
peux pas sortir en bas oui parce qu'ils
étaient au cachot hall alors tu es
tellement cachot supprime ce nom ça
c'est puéril bien après avoir beaucoup
réfléchi discuté avec les autres voilà
la sentence tu sortiras mardi ouais
parce que dans deux jours il fera beau
et je veux qu'ils aient une belle
lumière au moment où le peuple
assistera-t-on exécution
[Musique]